how do you deal with rejection how
what's the and also what's the lowest
you've been or you remember a time
period where you hit the lowest and how
did you deal with that
oh my gosh there's been I mean I've had
some pretty humiliating moments um
uh
yeah I mean rejection is
there is a uh
there's so much rejection in the
entertainment industry it's you either
develop calluses
or
I mean there is a psychological impact
uh that I think that
people might not realize like I have a
good friend of mine uh who passed away
and he
was
he he went to an Ivy League school
he went to an Ivy League Law School
he is uh he got a scholarship to a
special high school he was a home run
hitter
and
after and he did stand up and he
had a TV show and he had all this
success but the reality is is with all
that success that he had had through his
life
the amount of rejection that
he dealt with
aft you know like the show was canceled
the agent dumped him you know all this
stuff
I don't think he could process it and he
eventually got into drugs and he died
and the reason I bring that up is that
you know it's not an appetite for
failure or humiliation but you have to
have
it's a pretty tall task these uh these
uh these creative people that are paid
to take things personally to respond
emotionally and authentically they also
have to process all this humiliation so
when someone you know like Kanye West is
a bad example but when some actor loses
their I'm like yeah that's what
they're supposed to do you know I mean
but so it's that maturity
of
dealing with loss and uh disappointment
that makes someone exceptional you know
like Tom Hanks seems like a pretty
amazing guy but there's also
how he's processed the humiliation we
haven't seen is really impressive right
yeah and so but yeah I would say the
lowest point I mean I remember there was
there was a point where
so in the comedy club world again this
is when I was like all my friends were
uh you know getting on uh Conan getting
these measuring points that uh seem to
exist in the stand-up world
and I was getting nothing and I was not
working at some fan at the preeminent
Club because I was a low energy kind of
uh
observational guy that like
did not kind of uh stylistically their
reverence wasn't appealing it wasn't
working at one in the morning